This is Jocko podcast number
18 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
He who fights with monsters should be
careful lest he thereby become a monster.
And if thou gies long into the abyss,
the abyss,
we'll also gaze into the
so said Nietzsche.
Okay.
And that is really what we're
dealing with here in the world.
In my world,
fighting,
fighting against a monsters.
And I'm talking about,
okay,
what goes on not only in the outside
world and the evil that's there,
but also when the world around
us and also inside your head.
Inside my head,
there's battles,
battles that can be raging
every minute of the day between strength
and weakness between the past and the
future,
between good and evil,
between light and dark, opposing
forces battling against each other.
And we,
we all see evil.
I mean,
of course there's those of us that have
been to war where we see concentrated
evil but evils everywhere around us,
around everyone.
Disease and crime and
murder and abuse and loss.
And there's predators out there.
Yeah.
And there's prey
in nature and in humans.
And as I've said before,
there's parts of the world
where we've built a nice bubble
where we can all but remove the evil
or at least distance ourselves from it.
And in doing so,
we can almost almost forget about it
almost,
but it's a thin,
thin veneer,
okay?
And it doesn't take much
to release the demons.
It doesn't take much for
humanity to fall apart.
And that shows itself often in war,
which is one of those things
that can very quickly release the demons.
There are dead soldiers,
dead women, dead children.
Everyone's dead,
okay?
Shorn headed boys, sometimes
morose, sometimes laughing,
beaten up in our barracks were
broken jaws and ruptured lungs.
We were herded into this war
and killed by the hundred.
We didn't even know how to shoot.
We couldn't kill anyone.
We didn't know how all that we were
capable of was crying and dying
and die.
We did.
We called the rebels uncle and
when our boys throats were cut,
they begged the rebels, please uncle,
don't kill me. What did I ever do to you?
We so wanted to live. Get
that into your heads. You fat,
smug generals.
Who sent us off to this slaughter.
We hadn't yet seen life
or even tasted it's sent,
but we had already seen death.
We knew this smell of congealed blood on
the floor of a helicopter in a hundred
degree heat knew that the flesh of a torn
off leg turns black and that a person
can burn up entirely in lit
gasoline leaving just the bones.
We knew that body swell up in the heat
and we listened to every night to the
craze dogs howling in the ruins.
Then we started to howl ourselves
because to die at the age of 18
is terrifying.
We were betrayed by everyone and we
died in a manner be fitting real cannon
fodder silently and unfairly
by night. They'd kick the
living crap out of us by day.
We unload corpses.
I have no dreams in this tent and no
charred bodies chased me at night.
I just plunge into a dark pit where
there is nothing, not even war,
and I opened my eyes.
When it gets light,
a person changes very quickly in war.
He may be scared scared by a
dead body on the first day,
but a week later he can be
eating from a can while leaning,
leaning on human remains
to be more comfortable.
That's a book we're diving into right now.
It's called a one soldiers
war.
Okay.
By R K D Bob Chanko.
He was a Russian soldier,
fought in both wars in Chechnya,
the first and the second the Russians
fought against the Chechen rebels
and
this is actually a book that a bunch of
people after we did a short piece in and
talked about the war in Chechnya and
the lessons learned from that war.
A bunch of people hit me on Twitter
and said to check out this book,
and I did and they were right.
It's a great narrative and it shows you
the impact of this war on the soldiers
that fought in it and once again
we are going to see the
veil of humanity ripped off.
I think it's important first to kind of
look at where these soldiers came from.
Back to the book here.
You won't find any smart,
handsome boys and these tents,
they were gotten out of a war by
their rich daddy's leaving it to us,
ordinary folk to die and Graziani the
ones who didn't have the money to pay our
way out. Heap Denise tents are
the sons of laborers, teachers,
peasants,
and blue collar workers.
Basically all of those who were made
penniless by the government's thieves,
thieving reforms,
and then left to waste away.
These tents contain the ones who didn't
know how to give a bribe to the right
person who, who thought that the army
service was the duty of every man.
Truth and nobility of heart are
no longer virtues in our world.
Those who believe in them
are the first to die.
Okay?
Now, one thing that I'm
about to get into is the,
the treatment of the Russian soldiers,
which is absolutely just gangster.
It's, it's, it's just gangsters.
The only way I can describe it,
the way that the soldiers were treated,
the way that the military was run was
just by brute force within the own chain
of command.
So there was no escape.
This is what they were dealing with.
So there's an unofficial set of rules,
a kind of a code of laws,
which if violated,
incur corporal punishment.
If I stuck my hands in my pockets,
I'd get a bump on the head.
That is the privilege of the older
soldiers, a spirit and a spirit.
There's what they call the new soldiers.
They call them spirits.
A spirits should forget
about his pockets entirely,
otherwise they will fill them up with
sand and sold them the sand chiefs,
the groin,
and two days later you have weeping sores.
You can get a beating for anything at all.
If a spirit doesn't show respect in his
conversation with an older soldier of
Grandad,
he'll get beaten up.
If he talks too loudly or goes about
the barracks clattering his heels,
he'll get beaten up if he lies on his
bed and the day he'll get beaten up.
If people back home send him good rubber
slippers and he decides to wear them to
the shower, he'll get beaten
up and lose those slippers.
Okay.
And if a spirit even thinks of turning
down the tops of his boots are walking
around with his top button on Donner for
his cap is tip back on his head or to
one side or he doesn't do his belt up
tightly enough. Y'all thrash him so hard,
he'll forget his name. He is
a spirit, the lowest dregs.
And it is,
and it is his job to slave until the
older soldiers have been discharged
and then he goes on.
So that's sort of the,
that's sort of the basic
military situation that
they're in and that he's raised
in and that sort of the,
the garrison meaning not the combat
situation, but just the garrison,
the standard Russian situation.
If you're a soldier, now,
here's the situation he's in,
but there is none of this in our regimen.
All of that stuff is just child's play.
It's the big leagues here.
I can walk how I like and where,
what I like and it doesn't bother anyone.
They beat us for completely different
reasons. Our older conscripts,
I've already killed people and buried
their comrades and they don't believe
they'll survive this war themselves.
So beatings here are just the norm.
Everyone is going to die anyway. Both
those doing the beating and their victims,
so what's the big deal?
There's the runway two steps from here
and they keep bringing back bodies by the
dozen. We'll all die here.
Everybody beats everyone.
The devils with three
months of service to go.
The officer's the warrant officers,
they get stinking drunk and
then hammer the ones below them.
Even the colonel's beat the majors,
the majors beat the lieutenants and
they all beat the privates and the Grand
Dad's beat. The new recruits, no one
talks to each other like human beings.
They just smack each other in the
mouth because it's easier that way.
Quicker and simpler to understand because
you're all going to bite it anyways.
You bitches because there
are unfed children back home
because the officer Corps
addled with impoverishment
and hopelessness because
the devil has three months
left because every second man is shell
shocked because our motherland makes us
kill our own people,
our own people who speak Russian and we
have to shoot them in the head and send
their brains up.
Walls,
crush them with tanks and tear them to
pieces because these people want to kill
you because your soldiers
arrived yesterday straight
from training and today the
already lying open on the airstrip as
lumped lumps of charred flesh and flies
lay eggs in there,
open eyes.
And because in a day the company has
reduced to less than a third and God
willing,
you'll stay among that third because the
one thing that everyone knows is how to
get drunk and kill,
kill and kill some more.
Because a soldier is a stinking Rach and
a spirit doesn't have any right to live
at all and to beat him is
actually to do him a favor.
Okay,
I'll teach you what war is
about you pricks. You can have,
you can all have a smack in the mouth
so you don't think life is too rosy and
thank your mother that she didn't
have you six months earlier or you,
you'd all be dead now.
Everyone hates everyone
else in this regimen.
The hatred and madness hang over the
square like a flower black cloud.
And this cloud saturates
young boys with fear,
just like pieces of barbecue meat
being marinated in lemon juice only.
They get stewed and fear and hatred before
they get sent off to the meat grinder.
It will be easy.
It will be easier for us to die there.
So you've got some, uh, you know,
the things were the things you
hear me talking about all the time,
the camaraderie, the, the, a spree decor,
the Brotherhood,
all of it's just gone.
Now you're going to get to a point in any,
he does get to it where you get to the
frontline troopers when they're fighting
and they rely on each other and
they have the normal soldierly,
brotherly comrade love for each other.
But as a unit,
throughout the ranks, you can
see it's, it's, it's awful.
Hmm.
And this is before we
even get to the fighting.
Yeah.
Lev vanished toward evening.
He wasn't the first to go missing a couple
of weeks earlier to soldiers from the
eighth company had taken a
machine gun and tried to go home.
No one looked for your cove lev.
The storming of grass knee was underway
and second battalion tried in vain for
the third day to take the cross
shaped hospital suffering,
high casualties and we were bogged down
for the third day at the first row of
houses in the private district.
The storming operation was faltering
and we didn't have time to look.
They listed him as a deserter,
wrote off his rifle as lost in and closed
the case.
It was the old man and this
is like they're a sort of
a special police unit that
they had within the military Oman.
It was the Oman who turned up are missing
man during the night while they were
mopping up in the first
line in one cottage seller,
they found a mutilated body.
The rebels had slid him
open like a tin of meat,
pulled out his intestines and use them
to strangle him while he was still alive
on the neatly whitewashed walls above
him written in his blood were the words,
I'll Akbar God is great.
So now you get a little bit from the enemy
and we already talked about the abuse
and now we're going to get into some some
blue on blue,
some fratricide.
Half an hour later we got
shelled by self propelled guns.
I'm standing in the street with a company
commander when the first house on the
right suddenly shutters and
start to collapse in the center.
A huge split spreads down from
the ninth floor, balconies,
girders and floor support spew out and
seem to hover in the air turnover and
then drive themselves into
the ground with a thud.
Small debris scatters into the
yard after the heavy blocks.
We don't know what's happening
and squat down instinctively,
crawl behind a rusty shrapnel riddled
garage and look all around us than we
realize that it's friendly fire.
The company commander
fumbles for the headphone,
have the radio on my back and starts
to call it a battalion commander.
I crawl over to the spare radio that
standing on open ground with the commander
scrambling after me still wearing
the headphones, one after the other.
Him standing over my head and
me crouch between his legs.
We shout into the mouthpiece
for them to cease firing,
tangled up in the wires and
the headphones. We forget
all about the shrapnel.
All we can think about is reporting
that we are here and they should hold
shelling that we must
stop them from hitting.
Our guys are infantry men.
Pour out of the house and Stan dumbstruck
on the porches not knowing where to
run.
Huge hundred and 50 millimeter
shells weighing more than 60 pounds.
Roar through the air above us
and below up the upper floors.
One blast erupts, a whole vertical
section of the building vanishes.
Leaving just rusty steel end trails
jutting from the shattered walls.
Another shell flies down the middle of
the yard and hits the House on the left
before it explodes.
Time loses meaning we
lie behind the garage,
pressing ourselves into the snow.
How long this lasts, I have no idea.
Finally,
it's
over with too seriously wounded.
The shell that flew down the middle of
the yard exploded right inside their
headquarters.
While two men were there,
the leg in one side of them was blown to
pieces and the other had both legs torn
off.
Again,
we run the wounded to the carrier on
stretchers and load them inside again.
They make no sound except for when one
opens his eyes and says quietly get my
leg.
[inaudible] picks up the severed remnants
of the leg and carries it up along
beside the stretcher.
Five of them carry him in pieces for
taking his torso and one his leg.
They load him into the carrier.
The limb is placed inside behind him.
The other wounded man dies.
Some insight here, and I think
this is, this is a striking,
and I remember when you're a kid,
you grow up, you watch war movies,
you watch war documentaries,
you watch World War II films and
they're all in black and white.
And sometimes people think that war is
black and white because that's what you
see.
Okay?
And he thought the same
thing and here he is.
I always used to think that war was
black and white, but it's in color.
It's not true.
What the song says that birds don't
sing and trees don't grow in war.
In fact,
people get killed in the midst of such
vivid color among the green foliage of
the trees under the clear blue sky and
life hums on all around the birds brim
with song. The grass blooms
with brightly colored flowers.
Dead people lie on the grass and they
are not a bit scary in appearance as part
of this multicolored world.
You can laugh and chat alongside them.
Humanity doesn't freeze and go
crazy at the site of a body.
It's only frightening
when people shoot at you
and it's very frightening
that war is in color.
Talking about some of the civilians,
especially the mothers,
the mothers have at worst of all in this
war, they don't belong to either side.
They get brushed off from the Russian
generals or our or our soldiers shoot at
them.
And as one priest we freed from captivity,
told me the Chechens take them off
into the mountains and raped them,
killed them,
and feed their innards to their dogs.
They've been betrayed by everyone. These
Russian women, they die by the dozen.
Yet still they wander around
Chechnya with their photos,
searching for their sons
and what's happening to the sons.
Here's what's happening to the sons.
Then the Cheshin start killing our guys.
They took prisoner,
they shout from the end of the street
to get our attention and show a few
soldiers badly beaten and with
their hands tied behind their backs.
The Chechens laugh and shout something
at us and their language and then quickly
put one of the prisoners on his side,
on the asphalt,
pin his head with a foot and stab
him twice in the throat with a knife.
The boy jerks is tied hands and whimpers
and a black trickles spreads from a
slash throat onto the road.
The Chechens go back around the corner,
leaving him to die on the asphalt.
He lies a long time on his side without
moving and then he starts to twitch.
He jerks is bound hands and tries to
turn over as if he's uncomfortable.
Then he falls quiet again.
It is painful for him to move and he
obediently lies on his side with a gaping
throat that keeps pumping a black trickle
when we think he's already dead. He
starts to twitch again and tries to crawl.
Then goes still again.
This goes on a long time.
Blood pours from his throat
and smears across his face.
His jacket has slipped down to his
elbows and when he jerks his arms,
blood spurts from an artery
on to its bare shoulder.
Bastards says murky,
unable to bear any longer.
He jumps up and shouts over the buildings,
just kill him.
You fuckers shooting you bastards.
Bastards.
He on slings,
his rifle,
but OCIP POV and loop
managed to grab the barrel.
They grip his arms and
press him to the ground.
Okay.
Murky squats holding his head in
his hands and moaning bastards,
bastards,
bastards to he whimpered whispers
the boys soon starts to choke.
He can't breathe and blood sprays
from his mouth as he costs.
Sometimes he loses consciousness
for a while and lies motionless.
Then he comes to and once
again tries to crawl.
When he stops moving altogether,
the chuck and shoot him in
the back with tracer rounds,
the bullets pass through his
body and ricochet into the sky.
They also kill the rest of the prisoners.
This time they don't appear from around
the corner. All we hear are screams
before they cut each boys throat.
They shout all Akbar.
We hear this several
times and an hour later they throw
the bodies out into the street
savagery
and
unfortunately savagery
breeds more savagery
and the downward spiral.
Okay,
of sadism
and in humanity.
Meanwhile,
stories of horrors elsewhere in
Chechnya kept filtering back to us.
A friend of mine told me how his
battalion entered some village or another.
It didn't get shelled much
and was almost intact,
but around the main square,
we're large crosses upon which
Russian soldiers had been crucified.
They'd been nailed up by their hands
and each had a few bullet holes in his
chest.
They had all been castrated.
The commander ordered them to
do a sweep through the village.
All the men who could be found
were herded it up into the square.
They were thrown down in piles and
our soldiers started to hack them up.
One guy pinned to cheshin to the ground
with a f with his foot while another
pulled off his pants and with two or
three hefty slashes severed his scrotum,
the serrated blade of the knife snag
the skin and pull the blood vessels from
his body
in half a day.
The whole village was castrated.
Then the battalion moved out,
are dead men remained on the crosses.
As I said,
savagery
breeds more savagery
and
yeah,
here's one of the worst parts are,
I think this is one of the
worst parts psychologically for,
for this soldier,
for our Katie
and many of the soldiers that were
farting, fighting alongside him.
We don't know what we are fighting for.
We have no goal, no morals or
internal justification for what we do.
We are sent off to kill and to meet
our deaths, but we don't know why.
We just drew the short straw happened
to be born 18 years ago and grow up just
in time for this war and our blame
ends there.
The only thing we have is hope.
The hope that we will survive and
preserve our sense of self and be able to
remain human beings.
We all feel the adjustive at all.
We feel the injustice,
injustice of it all so
acutely with our 18 years.
Each one of us that survives this war
will truly believe that such evil should
never happen again.
Every shell that he had us tore
apart both the flesh and the soul.
Our whole outlook on life crumbled and
collapsed beneath this demonic fire and
there was nothing to
fill the emptiness in it.
The only thing we have left is
ourselves and our brothers in arms.
All we know of life is death.
If anyone ever asks me,
what were you fighting for?
I will reply for those who
clung to the ground next to me.
We fought only for each other.
Our entire generation may have died in
Chechnya, a whole generation of Russians,
even us.
Those of us who stayed alive,
can they really be those same 18
year old laughing boys who wants,
got seen off to the army
by their loved ones? No,
we died.
Okay.
We all died in that war.
Now there's a point where,
where are Katie, the author, he's,
they're under fire and obviously,
you know,
he's feeling the pressure of being under
fire and there's a sniper and he thinks
he knows where the snipers, but
he isn't, he's not 100% sure.
He just kind of thinks, hey, I think I
saw something. And he calls for fire.
You know the word she directs
heavy, heavy cannons, um,
from some armored vehicles
towards that fire.
And the next day or two days later,
he finds out that the,
what happened to the people that were
killed in that was like an an eight year
old or a nine year old
girl and her grandfather.
Okay.
And so here's his thoughts on that.
Yesterday I murdered a girl.
I suddenly felt sick and there
was nothing I could do about it.
There was nowhere to go and beg
forgiveness. I had murdered them.
And he was irrevocable.
Now I would be a child killer my whole
life and I'd have to live with this.
Eat, drink raised
children. Be Happy and sad,
laugh and cry. Be Ill, love
and and kiss.
Olga.
Touch this pure radiant creation
with hands that had murdered.
Touch her face, eyes, lips, breasts,
so tender and vulnerable and leave
greasy traces of death on her clear skin.
These hands, these damned hands. I
should cut them off and discard them.
I will never get them clean.
Now I stuck my hands between my knees
and started to rub them on my pant legs.
I understood that this was psychosis
madness, but I couldn't help it.
It seemed my hands.
It becomes sticky like when you've eaten
food in a dirty cafe under the sun.
Murder had stuck to them.
The vilest kind of murder
and I couldn't get it off.
The next day he's in the Chow Hall.
They're eating and one of his buddies
hands him a 10 with some oatmeal in it.
Here, eat this. We saved
it for you. Thanks.
I took the tin and absently.
Started to wolf down the cold oatmeal.
Then I stopped.
Remember how the Chechens hit
us yesterday? You know what?
It turns out we killed a girl when we
fired back an eight year old girl and her
grandfather.
Okay,
and here's the response from a whole leg.
It happens.
Don't think about it. It'll pass. If
you're going to put yourself through hell,
every time it happens,
you'll go out of your mind.
People here kill and get killed.
They kill us. We kill them.
I've killed too.
It's just war.
Our own lives aren't worth a thing here,
let alone someone else's.
Don't think about it.
At least not until you get home right now,
you're still too close to her.
She's dead and you're alive,
but you're both still
rotting in one place.
Only she's below ground and you're above
it and the difference between you may
only be one day
now going to a another little section
where they've gone into a place called our
gun and they've got a,
a pretty secure perimeter
and an old factory.
We are halted for the fourth day in a row
at the canning factory in [inaudible].
It's the best place we've been so
far during our deployment and we feel
completely safe inside the
fence that skirts the perimeter.
The trouble with this war is that we are
in a permanent state encirclement and
can expect to be shot in
the back at any moment,
but here we are sheltered,
we relax.
April has arrived in the sun,
has already beating down.
We rock around practically naked wearing
only are caught off long Johns and army
boots and we are,
we are like as brothers
and brothers we are for,
there's no one in the world closer
than emaciated soldiers with lice,
bitten armpits,
son Brown next and otherwise
white putrefying skin.
Yeah.
While he's there,
he's reflecting on some of the
things he's seen and he says,
I remember the photo we found near
shot toy of the little cheshin boy,
he's only about seven,
but he's showing off with a
rifle in his hands while as Matt,
while his mom stands alongside beaming,
had her little grown up son.
How proud she is of him.
So full of joy for the holy warrior
who already knows how to hold a rifle.
Okay.
There will be even greater pride in
her eyes when he severs the head of his
first Russian prisoner at the age of 17
at 20 hill attack a column and kill more
people and at 22 he'll
run his own slave camp.
Then at 25 they will hunt him down
from a helicopter like a wolf,
flush him into the open
and fire rockets at him.
As he darts between shell craters,
splattering has guts all over the place.
Then he'll lie in a puddle and
stare at the sky with half open,
lifeless eyes.
Now,
nothing more than an object of
disgust as lice crawling to his beard.
We've seen warriors like
this grown up from such boys,
from cubs into wolves,
and to think my mother would have flayed
the skin from my back with a belt if
I'd ever thought to pose with a
weapon when I was a kid. Enough,
no sense in dwelling on this.
Now later,
everything later.
So we kind of talked about
the suffering that they,
the, the abuse that they're
taking from, from their own,
from their own military leadership.
We talked about the friendly
fire situation to beyond
the harden an enemy that
gets raised to fight and on top of all
that there's nature and in disease that
they have to deal with.
Okay.
My bleeding starts again and my long
Johns are permanently and crusted with
blood.
We all have it.
Your rectum swells up and out,
several centimeters.
Half your backside hangs out and you
sit resplendent like a scarlet flower.
Where are we? Where are we
supposed to find wiping material?
We stripped the remaining scraps of
wallpaper from the store rooms and rasp at
our poor backsides inflicting further
harm on ourselves and sending blood
gushing from our pants.
War is not just attacks,
trenches,
firefights and grenades.
It's also blood in feces
running down your rotting legs.
It starvation,
lice and drunk and madness.
It's swearing and human debasement.
It's an inhuman stench and clouds
of flies circling over our battalion
and as time goes on,
he's sort of starting to
feel like the end of the war.
At least the end of his
deployment is going to come,
which starts to actually
intensify the fear for him.
Hmm.
I live with fear constantly. Now you
began that day and it doesn't abate.
I'm scared all the time.
The fear alternately turns slowly like
a worm somewhere below my stomach or
floods through me low
with a hot flush of sweat.
This is not the tension I experienced
in the mountains, but pure animal fear,
I can no longer sleep.
I don't trust the centuries and spend
most nights in the admin building or on
the parade ground.
I always keep my chest harness stuffed
with loaded magazines that have traded
for food and cigarettes.
I have about,
I have about 25 magazines
and it still seems to few.
I also empty a few clips of bullets
into my pockets and hang about a dozen
grenades from my belt. It's still
not enough. If they storm us,
I want to be fully armed.
Okay,
and that's how he kind of finishes
out in that complete state of fear
and then it's over.
The battalion leaves for where we
are beat to be discharged for us.
The war is over,
it starts to rain.
The tires of the vehicles squeal on the
wet asphalt and rainbow is glimmer in
the spray thrown up by the wheels.
I open the hatch and stick
my face out under the rain.
Large drops fall straight
in evenly on my skin.
The Sun hangs heavily on the horizon
and our column cast long shadows and its
rays
and that's it.
Peace.
This warm damp is the last day of our war.
Shepell is dead and so many others.
I remember all of my comrades,
I remember their faces,
their names at last.
We have peace boys.
We waited so long for it,
didn't we?
We so wanted to meet it together to go
home and not park company until the whole
platoon had been to everyone else's home.
And even after that we would
stay together, stay together,
live as one community,
always close,
always there for each other.
Yeah.
What will I do without you?
You are my brothers given to me by
the war and we shouldn't be separated.
We'll always be together.
We still have our whole lives ahead of us
now
as we hear a lot about these days,
the war ended
okay,
but it wasn't over.
It wasn't over for these guys
and
at this point are,
Katie is now
back in his back in the
city and he's talking,
he's walking around and he's dealing with
people and you're going to see here he
meets up with some other veterans,
wounded veterans that are
basically on the street
about a million military personnel pass
through Chechnya and the 10 years after
the start of the first war in 1994
that's the population of a large city,
50 divisions of seasoned soldiers
who bring their philosophy,
the philosophy of war back to civilian
life with them when they return.
Yeah.
At the age of 18 they had already killed
men who are sometimes older than their
fathers and saw how these grown men
died from the bullets unleashed by their
hands.
There were no voices of authority
and there was no god either.
They were ready for anything. There were
no women in their world, no children,
no old men, no sick people, no cripples.
There were just goals,
dangerous ones,
safe ones and ones with potential.
Three of them,
meaning three the veterans,
three of them meet and sit in the subway
near my metro station every morning.
They have five medals between them,
six crutches to artificial
limbs and one leg.
Okay.
And a common hatred for the whole world.
They've been coming here for a few years
now to sing songs and they are always
the same songs in the same order.
They sing terribly,
but that doesn't bother them.
They hate the people they are singing for.
They see the world from below and not
just because they are only have half their
bodies left, but because half
of their souls are gone too.
They're closer to the spit drenched
asphalt than to people's faces.
They no longer have the strength to get
up and start a new life on plastic legs
and no longer wished to.
These young men don't want to
try to keep up with life anymore.
All they want is for the war to last
forever and for them to be a part of it
for furnishings.
One of them brought a small travel rug,
a small kitchen to cushion
to sit on and a tape player.
When two of his comrades leave,
he stays there on his own.
I don't know his name and it
doesn't matter. He is my brother.
They all are brothers
given to me by the war.
The whole of Moscow is
filled with such brothers.
There's at least one in each subway.
He spoke first.
Where did you fight then brother?
I told him then he started
to remember stuff where when?
How? He told me about getting his leg
torn off. When his carrier got ambushed,
a shell hit the armor by his right hip.
He didn't lose consciousness and even
saw has ripped off leg jerking and the
boot scraping on the rivets.
I didn't ask him anything,
just listened in silence and he calmly
spoke and without any hysterics just
discussing life.
I don't understand this world.
These people, why are
they alive? What for?
They were given life at birth and
didn't have to pry it away from death.
Have a good life people.
But how do they spend it?
Do they want to invent a cure for aids
and build the world's most beautiful
bridge or make everyone happy?
No,
they want to rip everyone off,
stashed away as much money
as they can and that's it.
So many boys died.
Real kids.
And these people here fritter their lives
away as ignorantly as a kitten playing
with a ball and have no idea why
they are alive. Pointless people.
A whole world full of pointless people,
a lost generation.
And it's not we who are the
last generation, it's them.
Those who didn't fight, they are.
If their deaths could bring back,
just one of those boys did.
I'd all of them without hesitation.
Every single one of them
is my personal enemy.
He lights a new cigarette from the stub
of his last and pours a fresh shot of
vodka
and then he laughs easily and
his eyes flashed with hatred.
You can't go on enjoying yourself
while two hours flight away.
People are killing each other. Children
are still dying and there's starvation,
and yet those people are willing to pay
700 rubles for a theater ticket that's
2000 for the family just
to amuse themselves.
You can live for two months
and Chesney on that money.
I must be concussed because
I don't understand this.
I just can't get my head around it.
There's a war going on in their
country and they don't give a damn.
So in that case, why we shouldn't
give a damn about them either.
Not one of them should ever die
without knowing what war is.
I want for them to to cry out at night
and cry in their sleep and without waking
to dive under the bed.
When the New Year's Eve fireworks are
exploding in the yard and wine there from
terror like we did,
they are as guilty of our
deaths as those who killed us.
Who sent us to the slaughter.
Why weren't they striking in Moscow and
blocking the roads when we were being
killed and Graziani.
Why?
Why weren't they screaming and tearing
their hair out when they saw on TV?
How dogs fed off the flesh of their boys.
Why was there no revolution
uprising or civil unrest?
How could they send their sons off to
this slaughter and then go and have fun,
live, drink beer and earn money
while they were dying down there?
While jets were flattening the mountains
and tearing apart children and women
when wounded Cheshin kids rotted in
sellers wrapping the stumps of their limbs
in rags and infection
crept across the wounds.
There are also guilty of these deaths.
We are here to get what's
ours and we are ready to kill
his hatred of Bates as suddenly as it
it weld over his eyes recede once again
behind a film of indifference,
half truths everywhere.
Half sincerity have friendship.
I can't accept that here in civilian
life they only have half truths and the
small measure of truth we
had in war was a big lie.
So many boys died and I
survived the whole time.
I used to wonder what for
they were better than
I was when I survived.
Surely this is not by pure chance.
Maybe I lived so that others remember us.
I am a reminder.
He says,
okay,
it's
obviously a,
you know,
this is,
this is psychological damage and this is
someone that is still reeling from the
war.
And I can tell you when I,
when I came home from my last deployment,
okay.
You know,
I didn't feel like that,
but I understand what
he's talking about when,
when I came home from my last deployment
and knowing what great sacrifices
Americans were making overseas,
including my friends,
I remember walking around town
in just looking at people and
okay,
it is difficult to make that transition
mentally back to where people care about
the stupidest things and
you're complaining about
things that are just no human
being should ever be given
the right to complain about.
And as that individual
right there was saying,
okay,
kind of what I say,
what are you doing with your life?
What are you doing with your life?
Hmm hmm.
Because people have paid dearly
to give you that freedom.
So what are you doing with it?
Okay.
And now we get the authors view
and you can kind of hear
his struggle as well.
No one returns from the war ever.
Mothers get back a sad semblance of
their sons embittered aggressive beast
hardened against the whole world and
believing in nothing except death.
Yeah.
Yesterday's soldiers are no
longer belong to their parents.
They belonged to war and only
their body returns from the war.
Their soul stays there,
but the body still comes home
and the war within it dies gradually
shedding itself in layers scale by scale.
Slowly, very slowly. Yesterday's soldier,
sergeant or captain transforms from a
soulless dummy with empty eyes and a out
soul into something like a human being.
The unbearable nervous tension ebbs
away the aggression simmers down.
The hatred passes the loneliness of Bates.
It's the fear that Lingus law lingers
longest of all an animal fear of death,
but that two passes with time.
Okay.
And you start to learn
to live this life again.
You learn to walk without checking the
ground beneath your feet for mines and
trip wires and step on man holes on the
road without fear and stand at your full
height in the open ground.
Yeah,
and you go shopping,
talk on the phone and sleep on a bed.
Okay.
You learn to take for granted
the hot water and the taps,
the electricity and the central heating.
You no longer jumped at loud noises.
You start to live at first because that's
how it's worked out and you've stayed
alive. You do it without
gaining much joy from life.
You look at everything as a windfall
that came your way through some whim of
fate.
You lived your life from cover to cover
in those hundred 80 days you were there
and the remaining 50 odd years can't add
anything to that time or detract from
it.
Then you start to get drawn into life.
You get interested in this game,
which isn't for real.
You pass yourself off as a fully fledged
member of society and the mask of a
normal person grows onto you no longer
rejected by your body and those around
you think you are just
the same as everyone else,
but no one knows your real face and
no one knows that you are no longer a
person. Happy, laughing.
People walk around you accepting
you as one of their own,
and no one knows where you've been,
but that doesn't bother to you anymore.
You now remember the war is some
cartoon horror movie you once saw,
but you no longer recognize
yourself as one of its characters.
You don't tell anyone the truth anymore.
You can't explain what war really is
to someone who's never been there.
Just as you can't explain green to a
blind person or a man can't know what it's
like to give birth.
They simply don't have the
necessary sensory organs.
You can't explain or understand war.
All you can do is experience it.
Okay?
You're still waiting for something all
these years. God knows what though.
You simply can't believe that it ends
just like that. Any consequences,
you're probably waiting for someone to
shed some light on at all for someone to
come up to you and say, brother,
I know where you've been.
I know what war is and I know
what you've been fighting for.
That's very important to know why
and what for why the brothers,
the war gave to you had to die.
Why people were killed,
why they were fired on goodwill,
justice, faith and love,
crushed children and bombed women.
Why the world need to lose that girl I
saw on the runway with her smashed head
and a bit of her brain lying
in an ammo box next to her.
Why?
But no one tells you.
And then you yesterday's soldier,
sergeant or captain,
start to explain it to yourself.
You take a pen and paper and produce
the first phrase. As you start to write,
you still don't know what it'll be.
A short story or a poem or a song.
The lions come with difficulty.
Each letter tearing your body like
a shard being pulled from a wound.
You feel this pain physically as the
war comes out of you and dawn to paper
shaking you so that you can't see the
letters you are back there again at death.
Once them once more rules,
everything.
The room fills with moaning and fear.
And once again, you hear the big guns,
the screams of the wounded and people
being burned alive and the whistle of
mortar shells falling
towards your prone back,
the dead rise from their graves
and form up a great number of them.
Every one who is dear
to you and was killed,
you can already spot the familiar faces.
Igor Vaseline.
Four i's the platoon commander.
They lean towards you and whisper and
they're whispering. Fills the room.
Go on brother.
Tell them how we burned in the carrier's.
Tell them how we cried in surrounded
checkpoints in August of 1996 how we
whimpered and begged them not to kill
us as they pinned us to the ground with
their feet and slit our throats.
Tell them how boys' bodies
twitch when bullets hit them.
You survived only because we died there.
Go on.
They should know all this.
No one should die before
they know what war is
and tinge with blood.
The written words appear
one after the other.
Vodka is down by the pint.
While death and madness sit behind besides
you nudging you and correcting your
pen,
and there you are.
Yesterday's soldier,
sergeant or captain can cost a
hundred times shot to pieces,
patched up, reassembled,
half crazed and stupefied.
And you write and write and wine with
helplessness and sorrow and tears pour
down your face and stick into your stubble
and you realize
that you should not have
returned from the war.
And that is,
yeah,
where the book closes
and those,
those are the demons.
Those are the demons.
Why did I survive?
Why not them?
What about the innocence we killed?
Am I good for anything else besides war?
And it's not just a war
that brings out demons.
Life does
stress and mayhem and accidents
and crime and madness and loss.
Those are demons
that attack,
that attack your soul,
okay?
And there's a saying
and it's something like,
if I kill all my demons,
did my angels,
they die too.
And I say,
no.
I say,
do not kill your demons,
okay.
Instead
understand them,
know them.
It's one of the oldest tenants of war.
You have to know your enemies too.
You can defeat your enemy.
And the best trick the devil can play
is to make you think he's not there.
And that's what these do demons do.
They hide deep.
They pick away at you
and they set up on you.
But don't pretend that
the demons aren't there.
You've got to know him.
You got to understand them.
Bring them in, hold them
close, hold them tight
so you can control them
so you can recognize their form and
their presence and their actions.
And when I read about those soldiers
living in the streets, barely living,
lost on alcohol and drugs, I
think, at least in my mind,
it's not because they
surrendered to the demons,
okay?
It's because they didn't see them.
They didn't know that they were there.
They didn't recognize them
and they got ambushed.
Okay?
And in fighting
you own fighting.
It's the punch that you don't
see that knocks you out.
And in war, it's the ambush that
you don't see that kills you
and in your mind it's got to be
the thoughts that you don't see.
The things that you don't
acknowledge that you try to ignore.
The ones that you try and say aren't
there that you don't admit to.
Those are the ones that get you.
Those are the ones that drag you down.
Those are the ones that make you weaker,
that control you,
pull you into a bottle of pills or
of booze or into rage or depression.
When you see an alcoholic or a drug
addict or someone that has some f'ing
dragging them down,
it's often because they failed to truly
admit that that demon is there and that
demon has control over them
and they fail to recognize that
they can control the demon.
I see no, your enemy,
no your demons and that way
you can control them and
fight them and keep them at
bay
and you don't need to kill them.
In fact, I don't even know if you
can kill them. They're part of you.
They're part of what makes you you.
They're part of what makes me me.
I don't want to kill them
because if I killed my demons
then maybe I kill my angels as well.
What you need to put them in their place.
You need to control,
keep those demons in check
so they don't sneak up on you
and nash.
It ended up controlling you.
And there's one more piece to this.
The stronger that you get,
the weaker the demons get,
the more you control them,
the easier they are to control.
It just takes that awareness and that
ownership and that recognition and the
mindset
so that you can live your
life as you should in control
and on your terms.
Okay.
Not on the terms of the
demons in your head.
So
see them
and watch them and control them.
Okay.
Own them
and then live your life.
No,
once again,
it appears that I have
gone to that dark place.
Yeah. Who recommended that book, by the
way? Do you remember? Yeah, I, I'll, I'll,
I'll have to figure it out.
But you know,
I think part of that in,
you know,
you and I were talking prior
to this and I had to tell you,
you know, this is part of me. I,
I've attempted to sit down a couple of
times with the big positive podcasts and
I'm sure we will,
but
I got some demons in there
too that are talking.
Yeah.
And this is what they're drawn to.
And I want to face him.
I want to face him,
I want to look at them,
I want to go toe to toe with them.
And another thing is as
both full soldiers said,
people shouldn't get to live
without knowing what war is like.
Because until you know what war is like,
or at least until you open your
mind to understand what it is,
where it comes from,
what it does to people,
then that's a whole,
it's a whole part of humanity
that you're not seeing.
And it's the darkest part.
And you got to recognize that,
especially because if you don't recognize
that that darkness is there again,
you're not going to see the
beauty you have in your own life.
And you know what? That was dark and
that was deep. And you know what?
In the next 10 minutes, you and I
are gonna be laughing at something.
We're going to be Jim joined something.
We're gonna have some fun.
And I think in that respect,
the podcast,
it reflects life because life has ups
and downs and has misery and it has
sadness.
And it also has font and it has
laughter and that's what reality is.
And all those pieces for me that struggle,
the struggle and the pain
that is life. That is the
education. That's the reward,
that experience that you get,
that's what makes you better.
And I think that's why
we keep ending up here.
We don't dwell there and I don't dwell
there and I don't think people should
dwell there.
That's one of the best
things about recognizing when
you've got these things in
your head. If you try and ignore them,
they stay there when you face them.
Guess what?
I can move on and in 10 minutes you
and I are going to be laughing about
something. I don't know
what yet. Probably at you.
Mm hmm. There we go. We're already there.
The demon for the night has
been faced, my friend. Yeah.
Okay,
so now let's get to the good stuff.
To the light,
the Internet stuff, the Internet stuff.
That's right. Okay. The interwebs.
Speaking of inner webs,
we are in fact sponsored by on it.
But [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko to
get your warrior bars also known as the
anti iDonate anti doughnut, right?
Yeah. They had it tied down her donut.
Get Your donut, get your warrior
Barak, get yourself some good protein,
some good fat. How much
carbs. You know, it's funny.
Well you know what's funny if you're not
okay,
if you're in the mood,
like you know,
you get cravings for some Pringles or
something. I Dunno. Something makes
the warrior bar will. Yeah, it'll,
it'll, it'll save that satisfies.
Yeah. Cause it's all delicious. So on it,
on it.com/jack
will get 10% off. Boom.
Amazon couldn't go through.
Yeah. In the event of you wanting
to support this podcast in that way,
just before you do shopping on
Amazon, go to Jocko. And by the way,
this book right here,
the book that I read tonight,
I know it was a hardcore book and
it was real deep and dark in it's,
it's tough read, uh, mentally. But it's
also a great read. I forgot to say this.
The book is called one soldiers war.
I said it, but I said it briefly.
I'm saying it clearly now.
One soldiers war by our Katie Bab Chanko
eats a great book and go to Amazon and
buy it because it's, it's just, uh,
it's just a fantastic book and it'll open
your eyes to a part of the world that
most people try to ignore and I
don't believe you should ignore it.
So check that out and you can buy the
best you put the rest of the books on the,
I'm starting to put the back. Oh,
we're lagging a little bit like,
and that's my fault because I didn't
make it clear enough that you know that
that was important. Yeah, that's
absolutely true. It is not your fault.
And this one will be up there. That
one is up there. Put it that way.
A new one about excellent. Excellent.
So if you click through there,
you can get it on Amazon and it's a way
to support this podcast in the event of
you wanting to do that. And if you want
to shop for any of this stuff on Amazon,
just click through that, click
through our website, then you go and,
and then we get a little, a little
piece of that, which is awesome.
It's a good way to
support the, uh, websites.
We can buy camera equipment and so we
can buy new knives to put on the desk.
Actually we have a very good supply.
Knives,
got a bunch of cold steel knives they
sent out, which are awesome. Yes. Um,
and then yeah,
there it is.
And if you want to further
support the podcast,
you can get some shirts if you like,
if you think they're,
they're cool and need where discipline
equals freedom. That a cool,
and when the was head on it, it says good
backwards when you're looking at here.
So I was talking to a guy
and was basically saying,
hey, listen man, you know,
we were going back and forth.
We were texting and I
forget what started it off,
but it was something along the lines
of, you know, you've got, you know,
you got to just put your ego in check
here. And he said something like,
you know, we all need to put
her on. I said, oh no. He said,
I gotta put my ego in
check, ego in check. I said,
we all got to put her ego in check.
I go, I get to work on that too.
Of course we always do. And he said, yeah,
and I'm not the one that has a t shirt
with my face on it. And I said, yeah,
you're also not the one that wrote a 300
page book about yourself and who has a
podcast that's named after.
That's just your name.
So believe me,
we all got to work on it.
Well that shirt thing is different
because I made the shirt like that was my
idea to put this shirt like that.
And then, and then the, the bumpers,
the president.
But if you haven't seen those yet,
Echo made Jocko 2016 bumper stickers.
So yeah,
I did it for the greater good. I
guess that's, uh, I guess that's cool.
I wonder what kind of cars are those
going to be on? Are they going to be on,
you know, Volkswagens. Are
they going to be on a Mercedes?
So who's going to put those on? What
are we going to see? I think we've seen,
I think we see Fords and Chevys
maybe for the most part. Yeah.
Oh sure. Yeah. I don't know.
Get some European
vehicles in their t three.
We'll see you pretty good nonetheless.
If you want a bumper sticker on your car,
whatever kind of car you got,
um, you can get though that Jocko,
store.com as well. Um, yeah, sure.
It's bumper stickers, all this stuff if
you want them. All right, let's go. Cool.
First Question
Jacko.
As someone who has been getting after it
for as long as for a long time and has
incurred injuries along the way,
I see that you're a fan of MobilityWOD.
I've been into star at
stuff for a while myself.
Do you have any perspective
on the difference that
mobility inform can have on
performance, not just on
addressing or preventing injuries?
Did you encounter any material
like this on your younger days,
in your younger days as a seal at an
age when a lot of younger guys will just
slam through things as someone who is
still very active in your forties I'm
curious,
I'm curious to hear what your thoughts
are versus how your 20s self was.
Well,
so the first part of the question
about form and technique and mobility
affecting performance. Absolutely.
I mean technique these king, right?
In any sport, and it's funny
when you break into a new sport,
you realize how important technique
is because you think I can do that.
And then you try it and you go,
Whoa, there's a lot of technique.
Jiu Jitsu is a classic example,
but any sport that you play that
looks like it's not that hard,
you go ahead and try it. You realize how
much of a s every sport is technique.
So technique is absolutely important.
Mobility is also important and it'd being
able to move well and move smoothly.
You know, there's that whole, I don't
know if it's a trend going on right now,
but this idea of movement training, you
know, it's the same thing. You know, how,
how are you going to move? Well,
how do you move your body well?
So mobility is absolutely going to
make you a better performer. Now,
when I was younger
did,
I mean we just did not do this stuff.
It was just merciless,
no stretching, bad diet, no mobility.
And when we were sore or whatever,
we just just were sore.
I mean, that was it. Um, and, and,
and looking back,
I wish we knew more of that stuff.
We just didn't know it at the time.
Maybe people knew it. I didn't know it.
My buddies didn't know it.
We just did what we did.
We just worked out hard and just dealt
with the pain. And when we were sore or,
or had an injury, we just sucked
it up and just drove through it.
And I'm sure that's not good.
So I think there should definitely
be a focus on this kind of stuff. Um,
and it, you know, I think with one
of the thing that's, I think like me,
I need more focus on that because I,
I don't know enough mobility work.
I done enough for stretching.
Nevermind let's a mobility is like
a moderate and a stretching. Right.
And that's what actually, you know,
you know Eddie Bravo who's a Jujitsu,
if you don't know who that
is, that Jujitsu black belt,
really a creative game.
But he won't give somebody their black
belt unless they can do the lotus cit,
which is crazy. I mean, I can't
come close to doing a lotus sit,
which when you put your feet on
top of your thighs and he's told,
I've heard him talk a couple
times about, um, you know,
guys that were completely inflexible,
big football players. And then he's like,
hey, you know, you can't get your
black belt or you can do let us,
and these dudes just put their
mind to it and can do it.
So just like anything else,
you need to set some goals.
I don't think I'm quite willing to step
out onto the, I'm going to do a lotus,
but who knows.
Maybe that's not money,
just sat in the sand and
or and make it happen.
And I think though I think things can,
all people can go too far with that stuff.
And I've said this before,
like some of that extreme yoga where
you're just tying yourself in knots and
going beyond what a human is supposed
to be able to do and that's not,
I don't believe that's good for you.
And I have a couple friends.
I have one friend in particular
that was a hardcore yoga guy.
He was in the seal teams.
He got out hardcore yoga guy and,
and he said it,
he said he believes it caused a lot of
problems when he got older in his back
and his spine and his neck and his joints.
Cause you develop laxity,
develop looseness,
you have a higher probability.
So I think you should stretch
and be capable of the full
range of motion of what
a normal,
well oiled human should be able to do.
I think once you start putting your
arms, you know, backwards, upside,
down and behind and between your
legs and then back up again,
I think you're going to
have issues with that.
I also think I do get some mobility
from the workouts that I do from,
I do deep squats, right? I go
all the way down on squats.
I do a lot of overhead squats. I do
muscle ups, I do full range of motion,
pull ups and dips. I'm getting that
movement, doing surfing, Jujitsu. I mean,
you're constantly, you gotta stay,
you gotta keep moving, you know?
That's what I think you gotta do.
You gotta keep moving.
You got to move in ways that are varied
and in make you move in different
directions. Running,
swimming, surfing, Jujitsu,
all different kinds of working on just
getting after it basically. You know,
and that's another thing that I did
write down here as a note is, man,
when I was younger, w w we just
didn't tap that often in the Jujitsu.
And you know you,
everybody asks me every,
everybody that hits me up on Twitter
and says first day of Jujitsu class
tomorrow, what's, what's your advice?
My advice is tap early and tap
often because your ego,
if you let your ego control
the tapping mechanism,
you're going to get hurt and it might not
be instant. Like my neck is jacked up.
I've had neck surgery
that's from dean lister,
that's from being in a gay teens and not
tapping and being in arm chokes and not
tapping.
And that's from 20 years of not tapping
to that stuff because I can take a
pretty good joke. So it's cool that
you didn't happen, you got out,
but after 20 years, guess
what? You got some neck damage,
sun and it's not to get it written
originally in Bud. That definitely,
definitely buds had something to do
with it too, but just wear and tear.
But the additional wear and tear from
from Jujitsu definitely, you know,
I think had a little something to do
with it, which was all unnecessary.
It was just, Hey, I'm not going to
tap to this choke. It hurts my neck.
I hear some noises in there, but I'm
not tapping to it. It's not smart. Yeah.
Especially those neck ones because there
is an element of pain tolerance that
can help you in the next stuff.
But you get an Armbar as a new guy and
then you're rolling with another guy
who's kind of new,
but he might know how to do the arm bar.
He might be kind of spasming going hard
and unnecessarily because he doesn't
know the control yet. And
if you don't tap, really,
that's when you're getting get jammed
up. Tap early in, tap off in people.
Or if he start tapping right when
you feel the pain, that's wrong too.
Because a lot of times guys will put you
in it and it's kind of understood that
boom, you're locked in, you know
you're not going to anywhere.
So they kind of expect the tap. You
don't tap think, I might think, oh,
I'm not doing it right or I'm not a,
he has more flexibility as one thought.
One thought only crank
harder. Do it harder. Exactly.
Especially if it was locked in. So
it's like, all right, and then boom,
you're hurt and not good raw deal.
Not good
as far as flexibility though.
Um,
and Eddie Breville actually said
this in a way where, you know,
little kids like little babies, two years
old behind their heads, no problem. Yeah.
But for the most part,
but they're not going to do this weird Yo,
you know how like some guys are there
like double jointed or something.
They won't be able to
do that kind of stuff.
But so put loosely these two year olds,
they have full flexibility and you just
lose it over time. As you gain muscle,
you gain rigidity as your, you know,
everything gets stronger and stuff.
And if you don't put your body through
those motions, you just kind of lose it.
So let's say if you were
into stretching for,
from the beginning of the genetics
will play a part in that, um,
how stretchy you can be,
but so in a way you can get back there,
you just kind of work on getting
that works. Let's just like anything,
any workout. Yeah. But yeah, pushing it
too far seems kind of weird because like,
yeah, let's say, I don't know what,
you can stretch your shoulder way behind
your back, like way behind your back.
You don't have any really
real strength there.
But meanwhile it's so easy to be back
there and you know, and I don't know,
it does, it seems like your joints kind
of get rigid for to be stronger. Right?
I agree.
It's a bone before. Yeah, I
agree. Support. Next question.
How did the seals deal with fatigue,
soreness and beat down and the beat
down of buds and SQT without getting
injured? Well, you just get used
to it. And, and again, you know,
I say this all the time buds and the SQT,
which is the kind of the initial
training after you get done with buds,
which is the basic underwater
demolition seal training,
that's a short part of your career.
I mean,
it's literally a fraction of
your career means nothing. Um,
but just like any working out,
you get used to it.
And if it's like when you work out,
when you,
if you haven't worked out for a long
time or someone that's someone that just
starts working out from nowhere,
never worked out before,
they're going to be sore as a
hell when they first work out.
I just had this happen to me cause
I got, I won, I went on the road,
I went on a road trip, multiple backed
back road trips that I went overseas,
came back when I came back I got sick.
So I was for like three weeks,
I hadn't squatted heavy at all.
I had nobody at,
all I did was bodyweight squats,
you know, pistols, just lunges.
That's how I worked my legs. There's just
no way. So you just do what you can do,
you know,
hotel room in some strange part of Europe.
And when I came back I was all happy
and I got on that squad. Once I,
then I was sick and then once I got
done being sick, I finally felt good.
I got back on that squat rack and man,
my legs were destroyed
for four or five days.
I'm talking, you know, having
a hard time sitting down,
having a hard time standing
up. It was gnarly. And, but,
but that's just because my body just,
it just wasn't,
it lost that element.
So of course if you just started working
out and you're walking around sore all
the time, that's, that's, that's
because you got to get used to it. Um,
and in buds you do get injured just
because it's massively repetition.
You know, there was a guy that
we had that was a trainer,
an athletic trainer for a
professional sports team. And
when he was there,
there's a great example,
there's something called Patella femoral
syndrome, which is when your Patella,
because of the way you're running,
it rubs on your,
your femur and it becomes problematic.
And he said in like a whole season in the
NFL or he would see maybe one of those
injuries may be too,
and you'll have to figure out what it is.
And when he was working in buds,
he would literally see 30 of those a week.
So you just get to see, I mean there's
more people, there's 10 times the people,
but it still was massive
amount of injuries.
And it's the same thing in the
seal teams and the seal teams.
It's your shoulders, it's your back,
it's your knees, it's your ankles,
you get abused and it's,
it's not the working out that does
it to you. It's not working out.
It's carrying a guy on your shoulder,
over the rocky terrain,
out in the desert and tripping on
ankle bats. What? You get hurt,
it's jumping over off of a wall and you
land on a cinder block that breaks and
you bro, you know, it's,
that's the kind of stuff the working
out doesn't really do it to you.
I actually, wow. One of the things
when, when I was a tasking to commander,
we were going through land
warfare training and I would
work out every day and I
would roll with guys like teach them
some Jujitsu and enroll with them.
And I would, you know,
guys are, cause you know,
we're working hard during
the day or during the night.
And I was kind of making fun of some guys
that were taking Motrin and I was like,
you don't need that. You're weak.
And stuff like that. And sure enough,
right after we got done,
I got something called Bursitis in
my elbow because in land warfare,
you're constantly getting down to
the desert. You're crawling, you're,
and then I was in Jiu Jitsu on the mat
and I just banged it a couple of times
and sure enough, my elbow swelled
up and I had to take Motrin.
Yeah, don't, uh, don't
open your mouth Jocko.
Just keep it to yourself.
Um, so, you know, and again,
I was, I was hammering guys,
but in a joking manner. And so they
hammered me right back when I had the,
the Motrin pills to try and
heal that up. Um, but it is,
like I said, it's the, it's the,
the injuries come from not
from working out. In fact,
I always think that the working out
prevents the injuries. You know,
that I think that's true with everything.
I think that's true with Jujitsu.
I think that's true with life. You,
you, you work out, you're strong.
You're joints are strong, you, your muscle
density is better. Your, I mean, just,
just work out because it'll prevent
injuries more than more than I don't worry
about, I look at working out,
not as is going to happen.
I look at working at it
as injury prevention.
And the last thing is you shouldn't need
to like completely crush yourself every
day in your workouts.
I mean,
you shouldn't be going to a point that
you have massive muscle soreness over
your whole body or over even body parts.
You don't need to do that.
You don't need to do that. Uh, you know,
do you want to push yourself? Yeah.
You want to push yourself,
but you want to be so sore that you
aid like can't perform your job.
Uh, and also I like, you
know, active rest, you know,
I hardly ever just do nothing.
Occasionally I will
occasionally I'll just, man,
I'm broke down and just
eat steak and just chill.
But, uh, but I like to do the active rest,
you know, I like to do some kind of jogs,
swam, surf, whatever. And
you know, actually Jujitsu,
like if I have a sore back,
I love getting on the Mat. It just
loosens everything up. Feels so good.
But that's only at a certain level.
Yeah.
Cause when you're a white belts are a
bunch of belts or hope, purple belts, Ben,
that Bri and it's just a battle. You're,
you're getting off the mat. So we're,
I don't get off the mat so often. She did
too. Seldom seldom do I get off the mat.
Like man, I'm tired. I mean we train
today. I'm not, that was a no factor.
You know what I mean? It's just,
Oh yeah, we trained the pill.
If you get into the takedown elements
though, the that will even, yeah,
it'll be hard on your back. But even
the takedown elements, you know,
if you're just going to do pure takedowns
yeah, but I'm going to take down,
it's going to last how
long if your back sore,
full guard and work something
else. Yeah. So that's it.
In the bottom line is you work out,
you do some of these workouts,
you'll get used to it,
you'll get in the zone.
And then you won't be so sore all the
time. Yeah. That as that bucket of rest,
I uh, I that's important.
That part where you're like,
don't beat your doubt yourself.
Done. Cause the exercise,
it technically freely split hairs here.
The exercise doesn't make you stronger.
The recovery from the exercise is
when you get stronger. So yeah,
that was part of the whole
system that makes you strong.
But when you recover from that exercise,
that's when you're stronger.
I'll give you them. So, yeah.
But the workout itself is what
induces the recovery, so. Sure.
Yeah. So there you go. Um, you,
well I guess so it's all kinds
of different philosophies, right?
Different approaches. It's like
you, you prefer the active rest, um,
and not going hard everyday.
Some people they prefer go hard every day,
but then they'll have a straight up to
three days off. It's completely, you know,
um, but yeah, the, you know, recovery from
the exercise. That's, that's the tickets.
And when I say go hard, I mean like
the muscular, you know, destroy,
like if you can do squats until you can't
walk, you can't do that all the time.
Yeah. You don't need to write,
you need to initiate the growth.
You don't need to destroy them. Yeah.
And, and you can do, you, you know,
you can put with them with
the metabolic conditioning,
you can really can destroy
herself a lot more often.
And if you're doing it right,
you shouldn't really be getting muscularly
sore from your metabolic condition.
Yeah. If you're doing it right.
Right. But then again, he's a,
isn't that really a spectrum as well? It
is a spectrum. It can be like a heavier,
quicker. That's the, that's
the beauty of working on,
that's why you should never
get bored with working out.
Cause you can change though.
Okay,
next one. Next question.
Jacko did you ever use,
do you do to in combat,
would it a striking art be
better for combat situations?
Okay. So, yes. And, uh,
definitely this is one of the
things where I was actually,
I read things about this and people say,
well no,
I mean why would a seal ever have to
use, you know, hand to hand combat?
They have a rifle, they have a pistol,
they've got buddies with them. So you,
if you've, if you have to
use your hand to hand combat,
you've done something wrong.
And that's actually completely wrong
because you know, it's very simple.
You go into a room where there's people
in there and none of them were armed and
you have to get control of them.
You just start shooting people.
You're going to have to get control them.
Right.
So how do you get control
of them? Well, again,
how does striking give you control of
someone? The answer is it does not.
Unless you have a miracle touch that
you can just knock people out with one
touch and then you can handcuff them.
People don't,
boxers don't knock each other
out consistently. You know,
it's,
it's very difficult to knock someone out.
And so this idea that, you
know, striking is better.
You absolutely have to know how to strike,
but striking is a very,
a very inconsistent way to
get control of somebody. Very,
very inconsistent way
of controlling people.
And actually the sad thing is is that
it's striking is the most traumatic to
the, to the person that you're
applying it to. And you know,
we used to do something or we were taught
something called the muzzle strike,
right?
Where you'd basically hit the person with
the muzzle of your gun and the people
that were teaching it would
be like thinking that that
just stopped people like
Yo, you give them one good muscle strike
because it does, it seems like, you know,
a muzzle is a very strong, I mean a very
small point of impact and you think all,
if I put all my force behind
this small point of impact, man,
it's really going to hurt
somebody and take them down.
And I saw hundreds of muzzle strikes
and they're really brutal and they,
what they do is they cut you,
they cut you open very badly as a
lot of really bad cuts with rifle,
a rifle and a,
but they sell them.
Did they actually knock the person out?
So what do you do then you muzzle strike
them again and then what do you do
after that? You muzzle strike
him again and when you do it,
so you end up just to beat in a
meeting them Dang. But it's, but it's,
but it's a harsh beating because
you, you using, uh, uh, you know,
a pretty sharp muzzle of a weapon which
is cutting them open. So it's, it's,
it's not the best.
Whereas if someone can get control of
somebody in the grappling type scenario,
get control of them, you know, clinch
with them, take them down quickly.
You can get control and very quick quickly
and they feel it and they resist less
because they kind of feel owned and
they also don't feel like you're hurting
them. Whereas when you're
striking them in the face, man,
what's your natural answer? Reaction?
If I strike you in the face,
you can put your hands up.
Well if you put your hands up,
maybe you're trying to attack me now I
got to hit you even harder. So it's uh,
it's kind of a kind of a bad deal.
So yeah.
And then once you get a person on the
ground, obviously the more you know,
the better you're going to
do. And that's why, you know,
it's good.
It's good to have that.
Well roundedness but you
definitely want to use, you know,
you definitely want to
have a good ground game.
You want to have good striking
too, of course. And, but
the Jujitsu and the ground,
the ground game is very important
because you've got to control people.
And in a combat situation,
everybody you come up against is not
a combatant and they still need to get
controlled.
And some people you can just motion
to them to get down and that's great.
And then you can tell him to
lay down and that's great.
And you can have your interpreter tell
them to put their hands behind their back
and then that's great. Or
you can say that, you know,
you can learn a few phrases,
which we always did. We always knew a
few phrases to tell them to, you know,
get down,
show me your hands or whatever.
But then you get the person that maybe
they don't respond to what you're saying
and why aren't they responding? And
this is something I see, you know,
in some of these police videos
when I yell at you, you know,
get down, get down. Well,
you might be scared,
you might not know what I'm talking about.
You might have headphones on,
you might be deaf,
you might just be frozen with fear.
You might be a bad guy,
you might be getting ready to
run all those different things.
But if you're not doing what I tell you
to do, I got to get you to the ground.
So how am I going to do that? And again,
I can walk up and take a swing at you,
but you know, I've been punched
in the face many, many times.
Haven't been knocked out but twice.
So all the times I've been punched
in the face, you know, many,
many times, I don't
know how many, but many,
many times it's hard to knock someone out.
So if you think cause you
walk over and strike someone,
they're going to knock them out
and then you're gonna have control.
But it's just not true. It's
just a fallacy. So you're
going to have to know some.
And that the thing, this all goes
back to this, you know this case,
and I forget what the case was,
but somebody got choked years ago,
like in the 70s by a police officer
and I think they died or whatever,
but they banned choking. They banned
choking from most police forces.
So that's why these guys,
what do they do?
They pull out their Bhutan's and
start beating people. That was a big,
big thing with Rodney King.
You know,
why didn't someone just go and put this
guy to sleep and he'd have no marks on
his body? You know, he'd be okay. You
could bring him back to the jail cell.
He's not going to have contusions.
He's not going to have the crappy down.
We have no permanent damage whatsoever.
But it wasn't allowed because of the,
because of the political situation
that had happened years before,
you weren't allowed to teach someone how
to choke someone and put them to sleep.
Completely incapacitate them. Yeah. I
mean, the choke hold is a beautiful,
powerful thing. And when you
have, when you have, I mean,
you saw the Rodney king
tape, I mean there's, I don't
know how many cops or where,
but there's multiple cops beating him.
That's a classic example
of what I'm saying.
Just because you strike someone doesn't,
even with a Billy club doesn't
mean they're going to stop.
Whereas when you put a choke
hold on somebody, they are
going to sleep, you know,
they are going to sleep 100% and when you
have three cops going against one guy,
someone's going to get a
choke hold on. You know, and,
and despite what they did to Rodney
King beating him, he wasn't stopping.
And so yeah, it's one of those things
I really hope that the, uh, the,
the law enforcement gets the
ability to use, to, to train better,
to use choke holds to use other forms
of grappling because it is absolutely
superior from a law enforcement
perspective. And from a,
and from even from, like I said,
from a military perspective,
when you go into a room and
there's noncombatants in
there that you have to get
control over,
you don't want to start beating people.
You want to use the minimum
required force. And yet when
people aren't compliant,
you have to be able to do
something. Yeah. So yeah, the,
the minimum required force
that essentially makes
striking obsolete if you're
trying to approach it that way, or
if that's the regulation, you know,
what if it's not in the regulation,
if you're, if you're a human yeah.
And you've got a woman that is scared
or doesn't speak your language or as
petrified or whatever the case may be,
your answer is to Stryker in the face.
Right. And what does, by the way,
what does her husband do when
you strike her in the face? Yeah.
As opposed to if you come over,
you put your hands on or you gently push
her to ground, you feel some resistance.
Maybe you have to do some sort of
manipulation of a joint to get to control.
But that is so much more mild than
a muzzle strike to the face. Yeah.
And if you know what to do, if you know
what you did to the no brainer. Yeah.
And it's, it's not hard to do to people.
And even in you'll see sometimes um,
when when someone's trying to get,
you know,
gain control and they'll put their arm
behind their back like chicken wings
situation, they'll do it
all hard. Like real hard.
Cause they kinda got to
add that element of pain.
So the guy will kind of quote
unquote know bell most Jujitsu stuff,
you don't have to put that pain. It's just
that controlling. Like you just can't.
That's why a lot of people
were talking about this today.
How a lot of people after they get their
first time in Jujitsu or something or
early on and you did so guy will tap
them out and they'll have this thing in
their mind like oh I just have to
go harder. You know I can just,
I can gain some kind of control.
I just got to go harder. But it,
because it's not a hard thing.
It's not like aggressive feeling
to get controlled like that.
You're just simply controlled and you
know this ties so much to life cause we
talk about,
I'd be,
you hear me talk about this all time
and I was going back and forth with
somebody on Twitter the other day about,
I'm like you got to use the indirect
approach with people, right?
So picture this next time you're dealing
with a person that's combative and I
mean now I'm talking about
verbally combative or, or their,
their ideas are combative against your
combatives is the first thing you want to
do. Go up and punch him in the face
or muzzle strike them. Right. Cause,
what is the reaction to be?
What the reaction is going to be
able to immediately be defensive.
You don't want to put
people in that predicament.
You want to use the Jujitsu on them.
You want to,
you want to get them feeling comfortable
when you're going to sleep. You,
when somebody puts a choke hold
on you, you're done. I mean,
you're just going to sleep.
You sneak in behind. So,
so don't get this idea that when you're
dealing with people in a confrontation,
not only physically,
but a verbal or a mental confrontation.
I'm not even talking about a confrontation
in, you know, yelling in the street.
I'm talking about in the office.
I'm talking about dealing
with one of your subordinates.
I'm talking about dealing with your
boss or whoever. Think about using,
instead of thinking about,
hey, I'm going to, you know,
smash this person in the face and that's
going to bring me the win. No, it's not.
Generally, it is not generally what
brings you the win is, okay, hey,
where's what's going on? Let's sneak in
there. Let's get inside their head. Let's,
let's not aggravate the situation.
Let's bring the situation towards a
better area where we can use our control.
Yeah. You won't get the win,
you'll get a fight. Oh yeah.
You definitely get a fight even though
that's not the goal. Yeah. You'd be,
if they are combative and your answer
is to be more combative, you know,
and I hear answer, you know their answers
gonna be. Yeah. Even more so. Yeah.
Then you got yourself
a fight hener in them.
Gracie's they're doing good stuff with
law enforcement using you get to an
actual police tactics. So it
comes from, you know, in context,
if you're,
if you're a police officer out there or
you're in law enforcement in the hangar,
that's great.
Guess what?
There's a Jujitsu studio everywhere
in the country right now.
Go train some Jujitsu. Just go
start training. No big deal.
Just go start training.
Yeah,
and I have, I have a friend, um, Craig,
he's from, from, from Hawaii. He,
um, good copy. You see them on Facebook.
I'll like repost stuff.
Sometimes he'll like,
he'll come down to the skate park whether,
you know,
he got called or whatever
and he'll be ready. Yeah.
Do some skating or he'll race
somewhere or whatever. He's, but he's,
he's that you did too. I think he's a
purple or brown belt. Has the confidence.
Yeah man. That's what it is. He has the
confidence. Yeah. That's awesome. Yup.
Can Be be a good guy, you
know. Good guy with the power.
Next question Jocko.
How did you prepare for buds specifically
and where were you physically
wise within your class?
It must be a physical night around here.
Physical activity nights. Well that's
what the questions are tonight,
it seems like. So how did I prepare for
buds? Well, again, you've got to go back.
This is now 1989,
1990 and added.
I prepare for buds back then.
Well, we didn't know anything.
I didn't know anything. There was
no media, there was no internet,
there was nothing. There wasn't
even any books. So what did,
what did I do? And it wasn't even a week,
it was just an eye because I was alone.
I didn't know any seals. I didn't
know when he was at an, um, in,
in any kind of special operations at all.
So you're just young and stupid and just,
okay. So I just looked at it and said,
it appears that seal training is a bunch
of running and swimming and pushing
pushups and pull ups and rope climbs and
dips looks to me like in the pictures
that the recruiter showed me,
they were wearing boots and and fatigues.
So what did I do?
Went to the army navy store,
bought a couple pair of fatigue pants,
bought a couple pairs of jungle boots
that looked like what I saw in the
recruiting office and I
just ran with boots on.
I swam, I did pull ups, pushups and dips.
That's what I did to get ready for it.
There was no periodization
and there wasn't any plan.
There was no why wasn't
doing the Wad that you know,
there was no workout of the day.
I just ran and swam and did involves
pushups and dips and I did them a lot and,
and,
and actually I did them a lot,
but I didn't even know what I was capable
of or what even a person was capable
of because back then you could look
up on the Internet and say like,
what's good as far as pullups
go? Yeah. I had no idea.
You know, so I think I could
do 18 that solid. No, it's not.
Not when you're going through
seal training, but you
know, you just had no idea.
I just said okay, that's, and I didn't
know how to do get to be able to do more.
I mean I just did a bunch
and doesn't that work though?
I mean it didn't that work. Yeah, it did.
Yeah. I mean you do a bunch of pull ups.
Yeah. You do a bunch of pull ups
and you get better at pull ups.
You do a bunch of dips, you get better
at dips, you do a bunch of pushups,
you get better at pushups.
And Luckily I ran with boots on.
That's one thing that got
lot of guys had trouble with.
I think nowadays they use these,
they're almost like tennis shoes.
The boots that they run with
are like really light in
buds. They're really light,
athletic kind of boots.
But back in the day they were straight,
just hardcore jungle boots and, and a
lot of guys at Brahms, Shin splints,
stress fractures and all that.
And I was good to go because I was
used to running in boots cause I was a
knucklehead. And then the other part of
the question physically, where was I?
My class, I was about in the middle
of the pack. That's where I was.
I was not the fastest, I was not the
fastest runner, not the fastest swimmer.
I wasn't the fastest
at the obstacle course.
I actually failed a run when I decided
in my ultimate brilliance that I would
just pace myself for this run and uh,
failed.
The run missed at the time it gets the,
the run was supposed to be four miles,
but back in those days there was
no supervision on the instructors,
like limited supervision I should say.
And so the runs would be 4.3 miles,
4.6 miles to 4.2 miles, 3.8 miles. You
just didn't really know and it was fine.
I mean that's the way it should be.
And,
and actually you weren't
allowed to wear a watch,
so you had no idea what you're
doing. So I just said, oh,
I'm going to pace myself and keep
a good steady pace and I failed.
And so from then on there's only one way
I ran it was, it was as hard as I could,
as literally as hard as it,
when they blew the whistle to go.
I just ran as hard as I could
until the thing was over weight.
So why do you feel though?
Like did you just pace yourself too
slowly or dd pays itself and then shoot,
you started gassing anyway. No, I
paced myself and it wasn't fast enough.
That's it. I faced myself and
it wasn't fast enough. I just,
and I was there, I was right
behind the cutoff point. You know,
they're like boom. And the guy ahead of
me, he gets through and he, you know,
one guy ahead of me, he gets turned
away like, no, you failed man.
So I never paced myself again.
All I could do to sprint. That's,
that's the way a lot of the
evolutions where for me,
I just had to just go as
hard as I could because I,
I wasn't the best at any of it.
And
the only thing I was maybe a
little bit better at was anything,
I've talked about this before, we have
anything that I had to carry weight,
like a rucksack. I was a little
bit better at the normal. No,
definitely not stellar,
but um, but you know,
I had a,
I had an NCL NCAA water polo champion
in my buds class and I had a Olympic
alternate gymnast in my Buds Class.
And both those guys were stud
athletes. I mean, they're both,
I mean those are some of the top,
top athletes in the world. I mean,
if you win the NCAA championships of
water polo and you're an Olympic alternate
gymnast, you know, you're
just a of specimen.
And both of those guys
quit. Yeah. And there I was,
Joe average. But uh, yeah,
the bottom line is though, you get
to the, you get to the seal teams,
no one cares about buds.
No one cares about that stuff.
It's a baseline of training and that's it.
That's why I don't talk about it
that often. It's like who cares?
He and bud was there like
people who would, um,
like let's say I was really
good at running miles. Was
there people who would be,
you could tell they were showing
off to be like first, you know, oh,
everyone's trying to win. They're
gonna start to go first. And if you,
if you ran track more cross country,
you are going to be fine in buds for
running unless you got stress fractures.
If you swam or you played
water polo or whatever,
you are going to be fine in the running.
So if you did some kind of high school
sport that was related to those two,
you are going to be pretty good to
go. Yeah. But where they'd like, oh,
so when you say they were trying to
win, they're trying to be first. Yeah,
of course. Everyone's trying to win. Yeah.
And this is, I mean, right, aren't you?
I am. It seems like I, yeah,
I tried. Yeah, I guess. Yeah, you're in
that situation, right? You're Beth win.
Be The guy, the man. Next question.
Let's do it.
One of the most powerful tools I've
used as a military leader is rehearsals.
I would love to hear your thoughts
on rehearsals. So rehearsals,
and this is actually shocking
that I've never about rehearsals.
Rehearsals like what? Like, oh, we're
going to do it. You're doing a commission,
like a dresser and a practice for you.
And they're totally critical.
And one of the biggest parts of
preparing for an operation correctly,
you know, we used to have this,
they used to say one third planning,
one third gear prep,
and one third rehearsals.
That's how you're supposed to
spend your time. And it's, it's a,
it's a rule that gets violated very
often because people spend too much time
planning and not enough time rehearsing.
So we would always,
I would always try and push the rehearsals
as much as possible and I would,
when I was, uh, when I
was in charge of troops,
I would try and push rehearsals and then
when I was training troops I would try
and get them to rehearse.
But it's hard. Like I said,
people get drawn into the planning piece.
But a plan without a rehearsal
is not a plan really. So,
you know, definitely use the
rehearsals, rehearse as much as you can,
be hard on yourself during rehearsals,
rehearse contingencies.
That's something we used to do that I
was pretty intent on was rehearsing the
contingency.
So what could go wrong here?
What could go different
at the target area?
What's a different alternate route that
we might have to hit the target from?
And just just go through a
couple of those contingencies.
And actually when you do that,
make sure you, if you are hearse,
a couple continuing, if you
rehearse your, your main plan,
let's say you walk through it three times,
then you rehearse two
or three contingencies,
go back and do the main
plan two more times.
Just so that's what they leave with
the, you want that in their heads. They,
you want that in their heads because
otherwise it'll be a little bit of
confusion. But you definitely want to
rehearse some contingencies as well.
And we also would rehearse the things
that were the things that happened all the
time. So even, you know, a good
example was like are breached team,
which is the team that kind of goes in
to blow up a door so you can get in the
building and they have
their little procedures.
We'd heard that Bruce preaching would
rehearse over and over and over again so
that they're really just smooth and good
and they don't have to talk and they
can do things very
quickly. And, and you know,
the way we got into
vehicles now to vehicles,
we always rehearsed that even
though we'd rehearsed it by,
I mean by the end of deployment,
you've rehearsed that hundreds of
times and you still go there, hey,
dismount the vehicles and,
and get information because
it's just another time,
more muscle memory for everybody.
And you could do it with all the,
all the stuff that you do in the field,
you know,
whether you're calling it a
helicopter for a casualty evacuation,
how you're going to set up that landing
zone. You Rehearse that a few times,
just do it, you know, a couple of
times before you roll out an operation.
That way when it happens,
everybody knows what to do.
And this obviously translates
directly to everything else.
I mean, especially in business, I mean we,
we work with construction
companies and you know,
I talk a lot of times talk about with
construction companies because they lose
lives,
they lose money,
they lose jobs because they have,
if they have safety incidences and
how do they handle when they happen,
what are you do? So, you know,
rehearsing the emergency procedures
and when something happens,
rehearsing the setup before you
start a certain type of, you know,
construction operation, that's good.
Even with the sales world, like when I,
when I, you know, a lot of
teams that every business has,
well just about every business has
some sort of sales force in it, right?
Would that are trying to sell things and
how do you rehearse for them? Well you,
you do some role playing where you know,
somebody gets on and plays the
super hard client, you know,
somebody gets on and complaints,
how do you eat late?
Let's rehearse how you're going to
talk through when somebody calls up to
complaint and in two or three iterations,
people will improve on how they handle
complaints and how they handle a super
hard client.
How they overcome some objections.
But you do that through rehearsal and
it makes you just makes you better.
You know, it's um, you know that the,
I mean another rehearsal would be like a,
we work with the gas oil industry,
so how are they going to
handle when there's a leak,
how are they going to handle when there's
some kind of a ecological problem or a
fire or what are you gonna
do you know? Oh, you're going
to dial this number. Okay,
let's check that,
that number of my works.
How long has that number been in this
little pamphlet that's been sitting by the
phone? You know, when's the last time
that got checked out? Uh, where's,
where is the communications notes?
What if they get hit?
What's the alternative plan? So
just, yeah, rehearsals are awesome.
The finance world, we see
it as well. What kind of,
what if there's a drastic downturn
in the market or a drastic upturn?
Do you have a rehearsed plan
of what you're going to do,
who you're going to contact
if you have decisions to make?
Triggers have been hit. Just
rehearse that stuff. Yeah,
just rehearse it so everybody
knows and it's very, very helpful.
I know when I was in charge of training,
I had a very,
a very squared away and fired up a
corpsman who is our medical support.
And he just, you know, I talked about
rehearsals one time or whatever,
and he came to me and said,
we're going to rehearse all
of our casualty evacuations
for all of our different
training sites. So, and he did. And he'd
come back and he'd find, you know, hey,
guess what?
This is what I found on this one.
The life flight that we were supposed
to call didn't exist anymore.
They went out of business or they
changed their number or whatever,
or this Lz that we were planning on
using has a house on it now, you know.
And so we found real stuff. And you know
what this particular guy, great guy,
he in that time, he got all those
casualty evacuation plans squared away.
And in that,
in that year we actually did two real
casualty evacuation from training sites
for real critical injuries in
both of them went super smooth,
all because of his efforts
and they ran full rehearsals,
full rehearsals. And so just,
just that kind of thing,
those things save lives for sure.
Just doing those full rehearsals.
So yes, rehearse, rehearse and rehearse
in anything that you're doing.
Cause it'll make you better. Yes.
But I would think that anytime you're in
a situation where it being on the spot
is a big factor, you know,
where, where you have to make
a decision quick, you know,
you don't have a day or two days
to analyze and make a decision. Um,
feel like that would,
rehearsal would be a critical part of
preparing for something like that. Yeah.
And you can do that with
decision making.
Sure.
You can set up all kinds of rehearsals
for decision me for decision making in
whatever industry you're in just,
but what I like to do is make
those decisions critical,
make those challenging so that
you're putting somebody on the spot,
you're putting a leader in a spot.
And I'll tell you what,
one thing that's very cool about this,
and this is something you could
carry over to everything you do it,
it goes to decentralize command,
it goes to instilling initiative and
people you run rehearsals where the only
solution is to go outside
the box of the plant.
Oh,
during the rehearsal,
during the rehearsal or rehearsal where
the only solution is to disobey what the
order is.
And the reason I'm bringing this up
specifically as it cause you're talking
about rehearsing when there's
decisions that need to be made.
So this is going a little bit from
rehearsal almost into a training scenario,
right? So we're getting
away from rehearsal where
you're rehearsing a specific
operation into a training scenario where
what you're trying to do in training is
you're trying to get people to think.
You're trying to get people
to think on their own.
And that is the most beautiful
thing that you want as a leader,
as you want all your people thinking and
you want them to be able to think with
a completely open mind at mine that's
been completely freed from constraints.
And the way that you do that,
one of the ways that you do that,
one of the methodologies you can use
to do that is everybody's got their box
right that they're stuck in.
So you formulate a problem that the
only way that they're going to solve the
problem is to get outside of that
box. And you know, one of the,
one of the best ones is you put somebody
in a situation where you put parameters
on them and you say, Hey, no matter what,
you're not allowed to go across this line.
And then you put them in a situation
would have to cross that line.
And the only way they're going
to win us across that line.
And then they come back and they said,
well you told me not to cross that line.
You know what?
I didn't tell you to get you all your
guys killed or I didn't tell you to,
to not make that investment
even in this critical situation.
Or I didn't tell you not to do that.
If we had an ecological disaster
that was going on, right?
So you need to train
people to use common sense.
That's what you want to train me to do.
And it's very hard.
You'd be surprised at how at how
constrain people's brains get mine,
yours, everybody. We get stuck.
And so it's great to do drilling and
training where you are opening up the mind
and freeing the mind from any kind of
constraint where you can see things from
varied perspectives that
are different from your own.
And you can see outlets and solutions
that you would never have seen if you trap
yourself inside your box.
And those are the kinds of training
scenarios that are outstanding.
scenarios that make people better leaders
and better decision makers.
Because the key thing that they learn
how to do is they learn how to detach.
Even at that moment,
we talk about it all the time.
But if you can't detach
from that situation and you
can't detach far enough away
from the picture to see that the only
way you're going to solve this problem is
by going across that line that
you were told not to go across.
If you can't make that detachment,
you're never going to cross that line.
You're never going to open your mind.
You're never gonna see that solution.
And that is a horrible trap to be stuck in
the movie boiler room where the, during
the training, they give them a, you know,
it's a sales thing,
right?
They even miss index all these index
cards with rebuttals. Right? Like,
oh my wife won't let me buy
this. You know? Oh, your
wife runs your family, right?
Yeah. Yup. You ever see that
movie boiler room? I have
seen it. I have seen it. Yeah.
There's some good,
good training in there.
And how to overcome those objections and
people become better at. And the more,
the more you give them to chew on,
the better they'll get at.
It's the same thing where you're
trying to give people the tools,
but you know,
I want to go into that scenario and I
want to ask them a question when I'm
training them that they've never,
I want to give them an objection
that they've never heard before.
Let them think on their feet, let them
see, let them step back and say, Hey,
you know what? This one's
not in the cards. Where am I
going to go with it? Right.
Yeah. The card seems like that would fall
within rehearsal. Right, right, right.
[inaudible] expanded rehearsal.
Yeah,
I bet you they get 95% of the,
of the common objections that you get.
You know, you talked to a car salesman,
they hear x amount of objections.
You talked to uh,
a phone salesman or an aunt
or net sales men or you know,
whoever calls you up on the phone, they
hear the same, the solar people, right.
The solar people call you all the time
or the power company calls you with this
or the cable company, the other cable
company calls you with their offer.
They hear the same objections all
the time, you know what I mean?
So they train for those for sure.
Browse and me numbers of coming down to
Vons and they were like, hey, you know,
hey come here. I got
some tech this out. It's,
I'm the ones where you can
sponsor a child, one of
those kinds of things. Right.
So I was like, Hey, you
know, yeah, you know, we, we,
we donate but we like to research and
look into and before I could really finish
the sentence,
I was going to say we,
I like to look into all the programs that
we donate to or things are considered
delineating too.
Before I could finish this,
that or right when I finished
the sentence, he was like,
a lot of people are concerned about
where the money goes and all this stuff.
And he knew everything that was like,
oh, these guys are getting advanced city.
Yeah, man. Tough. He's prepared and
he rehearsed. Good for animas trained.
Next question,
Jocko for the podcasts.
What's your opinion on
calisthenics versus weights?
Again for me both,
I like them both.
You know with calisthenics you
get that endurance strength,
you get some flexibility
and some mobility out of it.
They're pretty natural movements,
right?
They're pretty natural movements or
things that you're doing with your human
body.
So they're going to be more natural.
Weights obviously make you stronger,
more explosive.
At a certain point they also
can be more injury inducing.
Sure.
And add another point.
They're also less injury inducing.
So there's a certain point where if you
have an injury in your shoulder and you
normally would do handstand pushups,
which means you're lifting up 230 pounds.
Well with weight training you could
lift up 40 pounds if you want to.
Right? So, so there's,
it goes both ways where
sometimes calisthenics might
be the more injury inducing
thing and sometimes weight training
might be the more injury inducing things.
That's why you got to balance the two of
them, you know? And for instance, when I,
if I like I hurt my ankle a couple of
months ago and I could not put any weight
on the scroll bar. So I was just
doing, you know, pistols and,
and you know, air squats,
jumps and box jumps, you know,
as using things that war didn't have
any way cause I could do all that.
But the minute I put weight on my
back, Yo, anything above bodyweight,
it started to hurt. And so I just
needed to let that thing he'll,
and I used the calisthenics to
get me there. And then the same,
exact opposite.
I had a,
my shoulder was tweaked six months
ago and I was having a hard time doing
handstand pushups cause it was just the
wrong angle. And so I was just using,
just using,
I was doing press with a lighter weight
than my body weight in order to keep the
blood moving in quarter,
in order to keep the,
in order to keep the system moving. Cause
that's what I think you've got to do.
So I think you gotta be, you gotta
find a balance of both, which means,
which means I'm not great
at either one of them.
I'm not going to win in any
weightlifting competitions.
And I'm not going to win in a
gymnastics competition either. And
there are some guys,
especially now,
I mean there's some guys that are
getting in sick shape. Um, you know,
you watch the guys in the
crossfit games right now,
they're savages and they're doing both
the calisthenics and the weightlifting.
And actually I was reading something
about it the other day and it's becoming
more weightlifting focused and you know,
whether it's Olympic, what is crossfit?
The crossfit, I shouldn't say
it's getting that more focused,
but if you want to win the crossfit games,
you got to be able to
lift some heavy weights.
You got to be able to dead lift a lot,
snatch a lot, clean and jerk a lot.
And if you can dead lift a lot,
clean and jerk a lot and snatch a lot,
you're going to be able to do. And at
least you practice the other movements,
the muscle up, the pull
ups, you're gonna be,
you're gonna be much more apt to be able
to do those things then the other way
around.
Hmm. So I mean it's for somebody that can
do a bodyweight snatch is more likely
to be able to do 50 pull ups in a row,
then somebody that's able to do 50 popes
in the role and that's their focus in
life is able to automatically
do a bodyweight snatch. I mean,
that's just the reality of it.
That's what I think right now. Um,
but the bottom line is on those,
I use both of them. I find,
I like to try and find that balance and
I think I use both of them according to
what my body prescribes me
and a lot of this stuff,
putting the book together,
that fitness Ebook.
So I got some folks that are helping
me out with it and they're gonna,
they're gonna, you know,
I'm gonna put these,
these things into the
fitness ebook at some point.
I don't know when it's going to get out.
This stuff takes a long,
you don't think it's going to take long.
Amen. But it does, it's um,
the cal settings versus weights.
Um,
it depends fully on what result
you want. Good. That is true.
So I think a lot of times you speak
kind of from the same, you know,
with the same results in mine,
but like if you want
to put on muscle mass,
it's real cut and dry. That weight
is gonna is gonna help you. Um,
and again, what's in my
opinion, interesting with, um,
like Kenneth Calisthenics. It's
a, uh, bodyweight squats, right?
Anything where you're pushing
your own body through space,
not necessarily with the weight,
but as far as that exercise has
more neuromuscular activation.
So if you do squats rather than leg
press that has more neuromuscular
activation. Oh yeah. But I mean,
I'm not saying that the, the,
but you're talking about also weighted
squats. Yes, exactly. Yeah, yeah.
Forever. Yeah. So basically
what I'm saying is it's kind of,
I haven't used any kind of
like weightlifting machine
and I don't remember how
long. Yeah. So like curls. You know
how you always do curls all the time.
Like if you did,
somebody said the other day somebody
posted a picture of some of the bumper
stickers on their squat
rack and somebody said,
we need to make a bumper sticker
that said like this is a no Korean,
which I got it, which I got a big
kick out of. And you know what though?
I will say this. That being said, I
don't think I've said that this. Sure.
I'll tell you what. I have a bicep that's
been a little bit bothersome. You know,
it's got a little tweak in it for a while.
Yeah,
it's been like that for awhile and I
actually will now do some curls to get
this, just to get that full range
of motion with some weight on it.
And I feel like that is,
I feel like I should have kept doing curls
and maybe I injured my bicep a little
bit from the lack of some focus
training around it. I could be wrong,
I could be wrong,
but I feel suspect of my
training methodology because
I hadn't done curls and a
long, long time because, you
know, you're thinking, hey,
why would I do curls when I can do cleans?
Right, sir? That's, that's sort of a,
that's my mentality. But
now I think, you know,
what do cleans and then it
wasn't curls to, you know,
work the bias of it. And the same thing
with, uh, with, uh, with the triceps.
And the same thing with all these
movements that I kind of tend to blow off
because they're not full
body multi joint movements,
which is sort of the gospel of strength
and conditioning. Um, you know,
I want to do squats, I want to do dead
lifts, I want to do clean and jerks.
I want to do these movements
where I'm using my whole
body. But I think, you know,
what,
why not accent those with some,
a little bit more focused just for the,
the additional work on a
focused area, the, and that,
and the benefit that, that gives you a
strength in that specific spot. So, yeah,
I'm sure. Uh, I'd love to
hear some opinions about
that on, you know, somebody,
you get some feedback to me and tell me
I'm either an idiot that evening or that
those are correct.
And if I hope I hear it's correct cause
I'll do it more than I do right now.
What, like curls and stuff.
Just, just, just more folks,
some focused body part exercises.
Well again,
and I think this is really important and
of course you're working
out for you of course.
I mean that's just the
nature of working out.
You can't and someone else can't get your
results from your work, you know? Right.
So again,
like I said,
it depends on what you want
out of working out. True.
So you know how you just said,
that's the gospel of,
of strength and conditioning
is that a full body weight.
So you prefer these things.
That's not everybody, you know.
So if let's say someone who's, you know,
he's worked in the office or whatever,
he wants to lose some weight
or he's kind of a, you know,
more of a skinny person and he wants to
put on muscle mass for a bunch of reason.
He wanted to get stronger.
He wants to be able to like push press.
Those people should do squat and dead
lift. Sure, yeah, agreed. Agreed.
But if you want to put on muscle mass,
like in your shoulders or your arms, both,
everything you do these other things,
curls, you know, not everyone's for that,
but that's not to say that that's
not a benefit Fishel type of workup.
That's a reality. Yeah. Not a
reality that I choose to participate.
You're already kind of, you know, you
have muscle mass, so it's easy, you know,
you see check yes. On hate on the
bodybuilding program. No, there's no heat
coming from me. Not much. Anyways.
All right, cool. Last question.
I'm going to write my ebook on.
Don't hate on the bodybuilding.
I want a copy Darko.
Do you ever compromise? And if so, when.
Okay.
When you're dealing with other people
in dynamic situations and relationships
and deals, you're trying to make
things happen. Of course, yes.
In fact,
I mean in many aspects,
leadership is really all about compromise,
about finding the common ground between
different teams and merging different
approaches to the same problem in
bridging these personalities of the people
that don't get along with each other
that you might not get along with
reaching agreements in different
courses of actions, all these things,
they all require compromise
and actually in many cases the failure
to compromise is a failure to succeed.
That's just the way it is.
But those,
of course those are all external
compromises with other people,
other human beings that have their own
personalities and egos and issues and you
as a person or I,
I have to work with them.
I have to make some compromises with them
cause they're not me.
But internally it's different.
I mean with myself,
I have to hold the line
and there's areas within myself
where I cannot compromise.
I'm going to work hard,
I'm going to train hard,
I'm going to try and improve myself.
I'm going to own my mistakes,
I'm going to confront them.
I'm gonna face my demons
and I'm not gonna give up
or give out or give in.
I'm going to stand
and I'm going to maintain
my personal self discipline.
They do my utmost
to live a life that is worthy
of the sacrifices
that were made for me and for us.
And on those points
there will be no compromise.
Yeah. Not now. Not ever
good.
I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So
thanks to all youtubers out there for
tuning in and listening and thanks for,
thanks for gutting it out when it gets
dark here and we start talking about the
horror,
the horror tonight and one soldiers war.
And when we did it with the forgotten
the Highlander and we did it with a
machete season,
I know it's hard to listen to,
but I'll tell you,
doesn't it just make the sunrise in
the morning that much more glorious
when the light comes into your world.
So thanks for connecting with us
through the interweb that this book was
actually from people on Twitter.
Okay.
So you all made me smarter and made
me better and gave me a different
perspective. So thank you for doing
that. Thanks for supporting the podcast,
listening, downloading,
subscribing, reviewing
and also the other forms
of support that we get.
Yup. On it.com/jocko that's
like a mutual support. You,
you're cool stuff and you get a discount,
boom.
And through Amazon you don't,
if you shop at Amazon or you can
buy books through Amazon, um,
click through the website, Jackal,
store.com or Jocko podcast.com and um,
you know,
you can do it that way or donate if
you want or get some cool t shirts and
bumper stickers and coffee
mugs and coffee mugs.
So it's okay if you,
if you dug this or you dig this
and you want to kind of see this
stuff that, that I talk about in,
yeah,
a documented form.
You can check out the book
extreme ownership that was
written by myself and Leif
Babin,
my brother from the seal teams,
and that's available in hardcover,
kindle or audio,
the audio book Lafe and I actually, the
chapters that we wrote, so if he had,
if you like listening to this, maybe you
like listening to that, check it out.
And as always,
Oh,
you troopers out there in the
field out there battling demons,
be they fear or guilt or alcohol or sugar
or ego or anger or procrastination or
whatever form of weakness
you are up against.
Fight those demons. Take
the fight to them, stand up,
face them,
get after it.
Until next time,
this is Jocko and deco
out.